want to know what's heating up in  theaters this weekend we all been our  lives on something question is what's  going to be a journalist examining  Christianity finds his own life altered  forever in the case for Christ you  really want to know the truth of your  mind already made yeah going in style  stars Morgan Freeman as a senior citizen  who plans a bank heist with his two old  friends  we're gonna need professional help the  Forbidden Forest is forbidden you're  grounded in Smurfs  The Lost village Smurfette and friends  must race against time to find a  mysterious forest village girls must  mean business see what's hot in theaters  with this week's anticipation  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]